[MUSIC]
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Hi,
I'm Cliff Samaniego
from Google Play Games
Business Development team.
Let's talk about Google
Play Game Services' Sign-in
in Best Practices.
First off, why should we
care about signing users in?
For users signing in to
Google Play Game Services,
it's the first step in
unlocking achievements, creating
competition with leaderboards,
saving a player's game state,
and opening up multiplayer
game possibilities.
For game developers,
getting users signed in
will allow you to utilize
Play Games Analytics.
If you're unfamiliar with
Play Games Analytics,
it's a near-zero analytics
feature in the developer
console that provides more
insight into your player base
and user engagement with
games that will help measure
overall business success.
From these insights
you'll be able to assess
the health of your
game's business
through performance highlights,
understand business drivers
through your games
active players,
learn about retention
numbers, and balance
your in-game economy
with sources and syncs.
This in turn can help you better
manage your game's mechanics
and performance,
leading to higher game
retention and monetization.
OK.
So now let's look at sign
in flow best practices.
There's three ways to integrate.
First, an automatic sign
in upon game launch.
Second, an automatic sign
in upon finishing the game
tutorial.
Third, feature a sign
in button prominently
upon launching your game.
Automatic sign in on game start
is the most effective sign
in option, and this
is what we recommend.
Here's some examples of good
sign in implementations,
"Clash of Clans" by
Supercell and "Marvel Contest
of Champions" by Kabam.
As you can see, after
launching the game,
Google Play Game Services will
effortlessly walk the user
through the sign in flow.
Another interesting
example of automatic sign
in is "Racing Rivals" by Glu.
Not only does the game
show auto login or auto
sign in upon game
start, but it also
provides a clear added value
to the user for signing in.
As you can see, the dialogue
box prompts the user to sign in
and shows the value
proposition of accessing
the game on all devices.
Adding automatic sign in upon
finishing the game tutorial
is another effective way to
ensure high sign in rates.
This is the best
for developers who
want their users to immerse
themselves in game tutorial
before asking them to sign in.
This is a trade
off between letting
the player get enticed
by the game early
and locking sign in thereafter.
A great example of this
is "Wonderball Heroes".
The last way to
implement sign in
is to have a
prominently placed sign
in button on the primary splash
page upon opening the game.
Definitely avoid placing the
login button behind a settings
menu or buried
elsewhere in your UI.
Here's a few examples of
how best to display the sign
in buttons within a game.
"Turbo Dismount" by Secret
Exit and "Top Eleven
Be a Soccer Manager"
by Nordeus are examples
of good implementations.
Let's check these out.
No matter what sign
in flow you choose
you should always attempt
a silent sign in whenever
the user starts up the app.
This will make sure that if a
user has signed into your game
previously they will be
automatically signed in again
as soon as they start your
game, no dialogue or button
clicking required.
A good example is "BombSquad"
by Eric Froemling.
Also, if you're going with
the automatic sign in flow,
you should track and
store whether or not
the user has declined
to sign in previously.
If that's the case,
then you shouldn't
try to automatically sign them
in upon opening the game again.
You should still, however,
add a sign in button
because you want to give
them an opportunity to change
their minds at a later time.
Branding guidelines for
Google Play Game Services
iconography can be found here.
In summary, there's
three recommendations
we have for sign
in best practices.
First, adding an automatic
sign in upon game launch
is our preferred method and one
that will provide the highest
sign in rates.
Second, add an automatic sign
in upon finishing the game
tutorial.
This will immerse
users in the tutorial
before asking them to login.
Third, feature a sign
in button prominently
upon launching
your game and avoid
burying it behind menu screens.
Now that you're armed with
our Sign-in Best Practices
go out there and get
your user signed in.
[MUSIC]